pues desde luego que son amenazas serias
tengamos en cuenta que kim jong y
amenazó el pasado verano con destruir la
oficina de enlace intercoreano y lo hizo
al final así que si amenaza con
desintegrar este órgano que menciona
perfectamente puede hacerlo kim jong es
una persona con mucho peso en todo el
régimen es subdirectora de un importante
órgano de propaganda y desde el año
pasado es además una de las principales
portavoces además asumiendo un digamos
un papel casi como de policía malo es la
persona encargada de comunicar los
mensajes más duros del régimen hoy ha
criticado estas maniobras militares que
mencionabas pero que a su vez han sido
reducidas en escala mucho debido a la
pandemia de este modo casi lo más
importante el mensaje más allá de las
maniobras es el mensaje que trata enviar
a seúl ya washington en vísperas del
viaje a la región del secretario de
estado y de defensa estadounidenses
anthony blinken y lloyd austin que
llegan mañana miércoles a seúl y es que
este viaje es muy importante para
ultimar y coordinar la que va a ser la
nueva estrategia de washington y sus
aliados regionales
con corea del norte corea del norte no
quiere un enfoque paciente quiere
retornar cuanto antes a la mesa de
negociación porque su economía se
encuentra en una mala situación por la
pandemia y como ya anunció kim jong-un
en enero y hoy ha vuelto a insinuar su
hermana si no se produce pronto ese
retorno a la mesa de negociación corea
del norte va a volver a probar pronto
armas nucleares y misiles